alors pas l'austère et donc ce roman
moon palace de 10 et qu'ils installent
parmi les meilleurs mais aussi
américaines ou alexandre 40 à 43
interview voilà vous vous mettez vous
citer cette phrase de jules verne qui
est au début de votre liste rien ne
saurait étonner un américain pourquoi
l'avez vous plaît ouais c'était pour
deux raisons je crois d'abord sa as ça
commence à donner le temps de
fantastique qui est dans le livret et
qui a pour moi exprime sa très bien les
fai américains rien ne peut étonner t il
avec un parce que tout est possible mais
je croyais et c'était plus intéressant
de citer un étranger américain ça donne
un peu plus de force
remarque je crois alors c'est pour cela
et j'ai ouvert mon sujet la lune aussi
mais est-ce que l'or vienne saurait
étonner américaine mais j'ai envie après
alors lu votre roman ne nous dit rien ne
saurait nous étonner et tout ce qui
vient d'un américain c'est la même chose
si l'un est possible notre lot suite
c'est vrai que les américains sont allés
sur la lune ils ont marché sur la lune
donc c'est ça les étonne pas ça nous
étonne plus non plus et la lune où
commencer notre livre avec une référence
sur la lune et se termine aussi avec une
référence sur la lune et le roman
s'intitule moon palace laquelle l
influence lunaire chance et c'est le
cycle enfin on parle beaucoup des états
unis mais alors peut-être vite je peux
donner un peu l'idée que j'avais bien
sûr en le faisant c'est que les états
unis c'est toujours le pays du progrès
ce progrès industriel pouvoir et ses
terrains et il ya dans la lune
l'idée contraire c'est les cycles
le temps qui ne change pas les choses
qui sera tête et je voulais y a trente
ans et le contraste entre ces deux
choses
par exemple il ya beaucoup sauf la
lumière la lumière naturelle la lumière
artificielle pousseur edison et
l'électricité c'est conflit avec tesla
tout ça c'est vrai que ça vient de
l'histoire est à la fois le la lumière
naturelle du soleil de la lune et tut
tut se charge comme ça tu t'es conflit
en conflit dans les niveaux
le héros s'appelle marco stanley fog
marco stanley fox ça veut dire qu'il est
promis trois fois au moins à l aventure
exactement marco c'est marco polo
stanley et ses lentilles a découvert des
mines stone en afrique les femmes c'est
le vert c'est le héros de jules verne et
voilà mais il faut dire que quand même
c'était par hasard qu'il a raison et
c'est son oncle au doctor qui est un
homme un peu bizarre chant classique qui
détermine que c'est à cause de ça qui va
sinon au début notre notre jeune homme
il a 18 ans il y à l'université columbia
et il n'a que richesse que 64 caisses de
livres qu'il tient de son oncle et qu'il
va vendre peu à peu pour vivre et puis
il va se laisser aller
il va devenir sorte d'étudiants clochard
dans central park
et puis va être sauvée par moment où il
va pour le mambourg et il va être sauvée
par l'amour de deux personnes
un de ses anciens copains puis une jeune
fille est amoureuse de lui alors moi je
vous dis je suis très simple ça pose un
problème votre roman parce que moi
j'aime beaucoup mais ils racontent des
choses graves la première à l'histoire
et les sinistres parce que c'est vrai et
en même temps tout ce que vous racontez
qui pourrait paraître cynisme nous
raconter avec une gaieté avec un allant
qu'une bonne humeur avec alors ça c'est
quoi là pour moi c'est qu'il ya une
raison très simple c'est parce que c'est
une sorte mémoire c'est quelqu'un qui
écrit sur sa jeunesse mais il est né
plus jeunes une autonome de 40 ans à peu
près qui a survie tout ça et ils
reflètent sur le passé certains
distancer money sur lui même mais dans
dix ans à mu il se moque de lui et voilà
notre jeune homme qui par petites
annonces
trouvent du travail auprès alors d'un
vieillard qui est immobilisé dans une
dans une petite chaise et qui est
semble-t-il aveugle mais n'en sais rien
et qui est le plus effroyable des
vieillards qu'on ait jamais rencontré et
qui va il va lui servir de secrétaire de
comment dire d'un prêt à oui c'est un
immense projet pas le dit oui et
finalement par les monstres et après
quand même peut-être doubler je l'évolué
et là il va lui raconter sa vie va
raconter à ce jeune homme sa vie et
c'est une vie absolument hallucinante
qui va alors qu'ils entraînent dans le
désert américain avec des personnages
pas sympathique du tout que me georges
lassalle gueule avec des gangsters avec
un ermite et d'assassiner est alors au
début on était chez beckett et là on se
touche et john ford bondissait c'est
tout à fait là je crois c'est un
souvenir des westerns que j'ai vu quand
j'étais petit et ça les jeunes garçons
de mon âge on était des cars borique
pendant cinq ans ou dix ans de ma
je portais des deux pistolets et je
vivais dans l'ouest alors finalement
j'avais l'occasion de décrire surfer et
romandie donc au fond vous rêvez à des
histoires parce que c'est vrai qu'on
s'ennuie jamais vous raconter sans arrêt
vous inventez les personnages qu'il
arrive une chose
l'action rebondit sans cesse mais en
même temps à travers toutes ces
péripéties vous rêvez de vous de ce que
vous auriez pu être des les aventures
vous auriez pu vivre oui quand j'étais
jeune bien sûr oui je crois tout le
monde fait je ne pense pas non parce que
par l'ong souvent les écrivains français
raconte au contraire ce qui leur est
arrivé
et n'en sortent pas et puis alors
troisième personnage le fils de ce
monstre qui est lui-même à mons c'est un
personnage 160 kg elle annonce qui est
là je vais revenir sérieux c'est qu'en
vérité vous raconter trois solitudes
avec la solitude d'un étudiant pauvre
qui ce retour dans central park
la solitude d'un monstre immobilisé dans
sa chaise l'immobiliser dans ses
souvenirs dans les mêmes dans les crimes
qu'il a commis
et puis la troisième solitude c'est
celle d'un homme qui est dans sa grève
est enfermé dans sa salle encore et dans
le souvenir d'une femme qu'il a aimée
oui et alors vous savez dès lundi il
s'appelait l'invention de la solitude
qui taperait beau titre
en effet c'est encore une fois ce livre
aurait pu s'intituler oui et il ya des
amis à moi après avoir lu par l'ès 1 re
lui des vins surtout l'invention de la
solitude parce qu'ils ont dû en parler
et j'imagine c'est vrai ces deux livres
un des records sur un fait c'est évident
et ce qu'ils étaient je disais tout à
l'heure vous avez écrit une anthologie
de la poésie française
je vous vois vous parlait très bien
français je l'avais trafic l écrivain
français allez vous traduis âgées
traduit un livre de chartreux sont
déniés des veaux oui c'était à situation
dise oui très bien avec des entretiens
g saint dié a aussi un niveau de blanc
chaud un livre ii des petits morceaux de
mallarmé déchirant pas facile après la
mort de son fils pour un tombeau dans le
turn
oui et et puis a récemment les deux
derniers bouts je ne fais plus mais j'ai
traduit à les écrits de miro le peintre
est aussi un livre très intéressant de
manille qui est très prochains mois fini
fictifs le funambule
ah oui j'ai fait du futur alors qu'on
évalue du trocadéro la tourelle
excessivement et entre les deux tours du
world trade center à new york et à on
est amis et j'ai traduit son niveau et
ce qui est étonnant c'est que vous
connaissez très bien notre littérature
et en même temps je n'ai pas du tout
influencé par l'opérateur allemand
je ne vois pas c'était plutôt un amour
de ma très jeune jonas est le français
et je suis épris par la poésie française
mais petit à petit j'ai suivi mon propre
chemin
est ce que c'est ce que c'est pas un
roman alors je sais pas de typiquement
américain lahoud fille qui nous
renseigne peut-être plus sont l'amérique
que plus bien d'autres et parce que pour
le mr est assez modeste dans sa
description son propre livre parce que
lui aussi à sa manière raconte les
années soixante dix le vietnam apparaît
aussi en filigrane tout tous les grands
courants au fond qui va traverser votre
génération tout roman américain si j'ose
dire il est typique 1,6 en tout cas vous
avez raison celui là l'est
particulièrement via le foisonnement il
ya la description des êtres des
personnages et des cordes et des
paysages il ya cette espèce de volonté
qu'ont tous les américains à mon avis de
prendre le réel comme ça avec le lecteur
et de les
mais en voyage non c'est pas du tout une
oeuvre européen s'est absolument pas
français ça c'est pas du tout influencé
par la vie comment il connaît nos
craintes et raturer alors une petite
erreur est commise vous parlez d'un
surréaliste qui est et ça c'est une
autre solitude qui ses fils et
maintenant c'est pas jacquerie bosser
jacques rigaud faute de diplo graphiste
par les conseils désactivés aux amis je
viens les auditeurs qui corrige cette
faute d'un an qu'il usurpe réservés
mais au fond c'est ça notre personnage
de l'échec à cet autre solitude qui est
l'ultime que dire de la mort de celui-ci
oui et c'est comme vous avez dit il ya
ces trois générations c'est celle mais
l'histoire était froid mais c3 pluriel
dans l'histoire des six états unis
russie
c'est le mouvement vers l'ouest et le 14
ce tract la destruction de mai et puis
il ya la deuxième guerre mondiale est un
gars comme semble atomique et pour la
troisième génération c'était la garantie
légale dans l'airial à 13 unités
pour chaque génération dans ce débat
alors ce qui est toujours aussi d'un
motif c'est que le personnage ensuite
rencontre par hasard son son père il va
apprendre que le monde c'était son grand
père mais ça c'est c'est les romanciers
ont tous les droits
et moi je trouve pas ça des lieux du
tout étonnant jetons peut-être tous à
leur mari et puis beaucoup plus d'être
voit la fiction tout à fait le trajet
longe sous leurs fonctions